last time we spoke to this man was just
uh I believe just a couple of weeks
after winning it all and he was kind
enough to call into this show in the
first blush of becoming a freshly minted
Super Bowl winning head coach and
sparking what has been called in the
city of Philadelphia the city of
Champions with Villanova doing it after
them and Philadelphia Sixers 76ers going
far deepen and now the Phillies are
close to first place he is Doug Peterson
here on the show how are you
coach hey rich doing well thank you for
having me on again and now that was I
was a long neutral but I never get you
know what you're told you know what I'm
just a long-winded guy there's just so
much going on in Philadelphia right now
- it does seem like you sparked
something don't you think well I I would
think so um you know with the success of
the football team and everything and of
course as you mentioned Villanova follow
following suit it's just exciting right
now so what else you want to be a sports
fan and you know the Sixers fires both
made it to the postseason and and had
good years and now the now the yes
Phillies I mean the Phillies are on fire
had a big win yesterday and just looking
you know looking looking good I mean
it's just a great great time to be a for
San Philly well I we have noticed that
the Phillies fortunes have changed coach
since you fired in a first strike
ceremonial first pitch rocking the the
old school holiday as well I mean we did
notice that you took notice well I
appreciate that that was a that's
president most nerve-wracking moment of
my my life was throwing that first good
job I couldn't say I wasted no time when
when they introduced me in the crowd
cheered I read back and I just threw the
ball in there I wasn't going to think
about it I'm glad I had the holiday
Jersey on gave me a little momentum a
little juice going out there and that
was a lot of fun yeah you fired it in
there you definitely do you have any
baseball history at all just high school
just high school you know I grew up
playing baseball and really football and
I stopped playing baseball after my
senior year of high school that's about
the farthest uh furthers my baseball
career went I'm watching batting
practice now on the TV side of things
you took me just did you go yard you
take it out I did I did not go yard I
think I hit a one hopper to the fence
we've done this the last couple of
seasons since I've been back here and
it's great to take some of the players
over there and and after we get our work
done during the day and the Phillies are
nice enough to let us take some BP on
the field and make it a little
competition yeah it's on yes right well
so now comes the turning of the page
right I mean would you say that this
part now clearly draft and and offseason
workout program beginning being one
thing but now OTAs that's a different
story would you agree with that it is it
is I mean that's the thing about it is
once you get back on the football field
but everything else just goes away and
and we focus on 2018 and you know for me
it wasn't just about you know just
shuffle in the deck and kind of starting
over all the way from installations to
you know how we practice meeting times
the whole thing and you know just just
or turning the page best you can and and
I but you know I don't want guys to
forget I think you need to remember the
journey obviously that it took but did
take a lot of sacrifice and and you know
we lost some good players along the way
in that journey so it's kind of a
bittersweet thing but yeah turn the page
move on and and I get ready for 2018
well I mean in terms of what proper note
to strike coach who have you reached out
to or who are you using as a sounding
board if at all to try and figure out
what is the right note to strike to make
sure that you are reveling in your
accomplishment but making sure that the
greed is still there you know I I fell
back on my days in Green Bay as a player
and I remember you know and Mike
Holmgren was our coach head coach and we
won the Superbowl against the Patriots
so you know in in Super Bowl 31 and then
at 32 we went back and we lost Broncos
and we were heavily favored that year to
win and we probably had a better
football team than then the year before
you know there in Green Bay so you know
I
just I was not to Mike Holden quite
honestly and I called him and just I
wanted to pick his pick his brain a
little bit on you know things like what
did he do you know structurally
different the second year you know with
the team was it was a lot of hotel
changes was it shake-up in the roster
you know I just wanted to I wanted to
find out I mean I went through there's a
player but but obviously wanted to find
out about it as a coach and just see if
there was anything that I could be doing
there to sort of guard against you know
the the chance of guys sort of you know
reading their press clippings as they
say and getting a little bigger than
than what they should and so Mike was
Mike was one of the longer former
coaches of every section Doug Peterson
Eagles head coach here on the Rich Eisen
show have you spoken to Carson Wentz
about when he does get back out there to
chill out with the headfirst diving and
get out of bounds get down that sort of
thing coach yeah you know we continue to
have those conversations we you know we
for the last two years we've talked
about that kind of stuff and and you
know it's the thing you really love
about him
you know is the aggressiveness and the
eagerness to to get as much as you can
but at the same time you sort of you're
cringing every time he takes a shot you
know so we just had to continue to
educate continue to talk and you know
just just keep keep working and keep
keep fighting through it but but for for
me I just I still don't want to take you
know the aggressiveness away from him
because that's what makes him very
special what is he what is he like right
now I mean what is he looking like right
now with the idea clearly you're not
going to name a starter for week one
right here on the Rich Eisen show
although I'd appreciate it if I'm very
honest yeah if you just go on record
right now um you know I'm very very
encouraged where Carson is just being AB
he's working extremely hard to get
himself back out on the football field
and and you know he's just doing
everything everything possible you know
to to hopefully you know be that day
on starter we're just we're just not
there yet with it and and yet still you
know still optimistic even with all our
injured players that they'll be ready at
some point and my biggest thing is you
know is I just don't want to rush him
out there too soon and and make it make
it any worse that has to be so just when
he's ready he's ready and we'll go we'll
go like that
well and I'd love to ask you in a few
minutes I have left with you about the
rookie quarterback class that just came
in and there's been so many comparisons
to Carson Wentz Josh Allen being one
first question just to maybe give an
idea to the fan base here just how deep
you go for a draft did you evaluate any
quarterbacks this year did you get into
that at all we did I you know I didn't
spend you know as much time with the top
the top-tier guys because they were all
guys on you know first I could round
which which we knew you know you know we
didn't you weren't going to be in that
in that market obviously it's for a
quarterback but you know some of the
younger one of those three four five new
ground guys you know we're guys that
that you know we felt if you know we had
the opportunity we could we could draft
one but you know we only had five draft
picks - so all right you know it was it
was a little you know probably
far-fetched that we were going to do
that but but my evaluation on these guys
you know was not as much obviously it
was extensive as it was when not we were
evaluating Carson and Jared golf and
Paxton Lynch and those guys come out
years ago right so let me ask you then
what I asked Andy Reed on the show just
a couple weeks ago since obviously you
know him intimately and John Dorsey
having come from there were you
surprised that the Dorsey Browns chose
Baker Mayfield atop the draft
no no because because that's that was
the guy that targeted that was a guy
that was going to be you know that's it
you know knowing knowing a little bit
about John Dorsey and and you know one
thing with Baker Mayfield is he he
definitely brings a level of excitement
oh love is love his athleticism his
mental toughness his whole makeup you
know as a quarterback and and you know
that
that's what uh you know that's what
probably attracted you know Cleveland to
him among other things and I don't want
to speak for them but but those are
those are things that you see on the
outside that would definitely draw the
attention to somebody like Baker well
and then then the Madhuri finished this
line of questioning with this question
then because all of us sitting there on
the draft set at the NFL Network well
who's got a chance to start this year
and none of us a couple years ago would
have said carson wentz on the day of the
draft and that's exactly about happening
right so you can never tell yeah but
what will so help help the fans who are
maybe thinking that their rookie
quarterback could start when when did
that moment for you come to a
crystallization that maybe whence it
could be the guy for you to start how
did that come about what did you see
well you know for us it it it that ball
began rolling back when we had our first
rookie minicamp two weeks after the
draft only drafted carson wentz and just
saw his his eagerness to study his
eagerness to learn and the athleticism
the arm strength the intelligence all
the things that we saw and kind of knew
going into the draft about him we were
seeing it firsthand on the football
field and then you know once we got in a
training camp and some of the throws he
made and some of the decisions he's
doing with some of the ones that he's
making the scrambles here it's sort of a
I have anything you know like this kid
this kid could be you know pretty
special at some point I didn't think it
necessarily gonna be our first year my
first year but you know then fast
forward to the end of training and he
actually had a an injury and training
camp that year that sidelined him for
three games you know the last preseason
games and even from that standpoint you
know we were still like very hesitant to
say you know he's gonna be the week one
starter but we went to Indianapolis that
year and had a preseason game in
Indianapolis and put him through an
extensive pregame he wasn't playing in
the game obviously but we put into an
extensive workout and really came away
feeling feeling very comfortable and
confident that this this at some point
possibly he could be our starter you
know in the first year and then of
course
you know a few weeks later we made the
trade with Minnesota unfortunate injury
with you know Katie Bridgewater so Sam
Bradford went and you know made the
decision to start to start Carsen my
first year his first year and if we were
going to take lumps let's do it together
let's get them let's get them out of the
way let's learn from each other um if
we're gonna hopefully be together for
several years let's let's start it you
wanted to hurt so that was decision to
go ahead and start in that first year
okay it's just good my food for thought
for for teams looking to see if their
rookie quarterbacks can can grab the
reins like that just a couple more
minutes left with you here coach Doug
Peterson the Eagles June 5th is set for
the team to visit the White House and
and there's been so much conversation as
to whether this team as a whole is going
to go or not have you had conversations
internally with the players about who's
going right now and who's not
essentially taking attendance right now
mid-may yeah you know right now we've
we've basically rich the way we've got
it is it's got the date scheduled for
June 5th I believe that's a Tuesday and
and you know we're working on the
logistics of the trip and and some of
the things that we're going to do while
besides you know besides the white hats
and you know listen I'm we're being
honored obviously as a team we'll world
champions I think it's a great great to
be honored especially by the by the
president the White House but you know I
do feel that that it's it's on an
individual basis you know we haven't had
necessarily internal conversations I
know we will in the next few weeks we'll
have I'll have an itinerary I believe
next week it's coming out and we'll be
we'll be able to have some more
conversation about it and somebody to
see who's you know interested in going I
know there's there's a group that's
probably a little hesitant in going and
that's fine I understand and then and
then there's obviously a group that is
excited about going so again you know
it's an individual basis but again we're
being honored as a football team and and
I hope we can hope we can go in and and
do it as a football well in terms of
those who are saying who are hesitant to
go should that group band together
away and say we want to go but only if
we have a conversation aw with with the
president separate from this
conversation II would that be something
that you would be involved in or is that
even being discussed in any way shape or
form right yeah you know what those are
things that I know some of our players
have brought up brought to our attention
and I think that that's that's a great
way of you know presenting it if they
can be involved that way and and sort of
you know because we've got some great
some some great leaders on this football
team that have been outspoken in the
community and have done some great
positive things here in the city of
Philadelphia and back in their own
hometowns and I think that you know when
you get an opportunity to visit the
White House that you would want a little
bit of time so those are all things
we're going through and and and
logistically working out see one how
much time and and we can have try to
maximize today coach really appreciate
the time as always
you know great scene I mean the the
pitching and the hitting and the winning
all of it it's been it's been an
impressive run for you so far in 2018 so
thanks for taking out time thank you
thank you rich I do appreciate it and
now we can know is that that's behind us
and we can focus on football yeah you're
a distraction when you're hitting in
your throat
correct take care coach appreciate it
thank you ready but that's Doug Peterson
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience